mesdames et messieurs bonsoir deux jours
après la tempête la situation est donc
en voie d'amélioration en champagne
ardenne l'électricité je vous le dis
vert revient peu à peu mais pour autant
tout est loin d'être réglée ce soir dans
la marne
de nombreuses communes restent privées
d'eau c'est notamment le secteur de
sainte menou et de montmirail qui sont
les plus touchés à montmirail
il n'y a désormais plus aucune goutte
d'eau depuis quelques heures ce sont
deux camions citernes qui ravitaille la
population en nous deux camions citernes
pour seulement 4000 habitants des
habitants aujourd'hui
extraits vivez vous avec quatre fois et
comme beaucoup d'autres personnes
cet endroit en face deux enfants à côté
du tampon pas scindé vais enfin mal on
est parvenu ce qu'écrit d'une autre camp
n'avait pas leur affaire de réserve
la colère des habitants de montmirail
sans cette famille de sept enfants il
n'y a plus d'eau depuis dimanche
alors on s'organise comme un rang qu'il
est ouverte dans les faits cela vais
donc vous ne gagnez donc on achète loi
stocks et ont fait chauffer de l'eau sur
le dos pour laver les petits aux plus
gros le château doit bien fonctionner
mais à peine quelques heures le seul
groupe électrogène obtenu par la guinée
est tombé en panne
à la mairie on est désemparés face à
l'ampleur de cette situation d'autant
plus le l'aide de l'état de venir aider
montmirail mur à check de 4000 habitants
qui au jour devant lui depuis deux jours
sans électricité sans chauffage est
pratiquement changé potables et usées
hier soir cependant une citerne de 25
musiciens for men pu être installé en
centre-ville
les habitants ne sont pas informés ou
bouche quoi ton problème pour 4000
habitants cela reste insuffisant
d'autres s'y faire l'arrivée hier
étaient destinés prioritairement à
l'hôpital de la ville qui accueille plus
de 170 pensionnaires